>>ALL THE LEFT AND THE MEDIA
ATTACK DOGS CAN DISH IT OUT BUT
THEY SURE CAN’T TAKE IT.
LAST NIGHT WE PLAYED CLIPS OF
NBA SUPERSTARS LEBRON JAMES,
KEVIN DURANT TRASHING TRUMP.
>> THE NUMBER-ONE JOB IN
AMERICA, THE POINT OF PERSON IS
SOMEONE WHO DOESN’T UNDERSTAND
THE PEOPLE AND REALLY DON’T GIVE
A [BLEEP] ABOUT THE PEOPLE.
I FEEL LIKE OUR TEAM AS A
COUNTRY IS NOT RAN BY A GREAT
COACH.
IT’S NOT EVEN A SURPRISE WHEN HE
IT’S LAUGHABLE.
>> BUT IT’S ALSO SCARY.
I SHOULDN’T BE NUMB TO YOUR
RACISM AND YOUR BEHAVIOR.
>> I CALL THOSE REMARKS BARELY
INTELLIGIBLE, NOT TO MENTION
UNGRAMMATICAL.
AND THE LEFT ERUPTED.
SLATE’S PIECE WAS ENTITLED "IN
INSULTING LEBRON JAME --
MANY CLAIM MY LINE THAT LEBRON
SHOULD SHUT UP AND DRIBBLE WAS
RACIST.
WHAT?
I WROTE A BOOK, 15 YEARS AGO,
FAIRLY WELL KNOWN, NEW YORK’S
BEST SELLER CALLED "SHUT UP AND
SING."
AND I’VE BEEN USING THAT LINE
FOR 15 YEARS WITHOUT REGARD TO
SKIN COLOR, WHERE YOU CAME FROM,
WHAT YOU DO.
BY THE WAY, WITHOUT A SINGLE
FACT ON YOUR SIDE, WELL, JAMIE,
ALL I CAN SAY IS YOU’RE FAR FROM
PERFECT.
OH, REMEMBER THAT MOVIE WITH  --
SHE’S BEEN HAMMERING PRESIDENT
TRUMP ON TWITTER FOR MONTHS AND
NOW FEELS QUALIFIED TO WEIGH IN
ON NET NEUTRALITY BECAUSE OF HIS
LONG DISTINGUISHED CAREER ON
SCREEN IN FILMS SUCH AS STAR
WARS AND STAR WARS SEQUELS.
SHUT UP AND SING OR SHUT UP AND
ACT OR SHUT UP AND MAKE US LAUGH
EVERY NOW AND THEN.
SO I’M AN EQUAL-OPPORTUNITY
CRITIC WHEN IT COMES TO
LEFT-WING CELEBRITY SOUNDING OFF
ON TOPICS OF WHICH THEY KNOW
PRECIOUS LITTLE.
AND AS YOU CAN SEE, RACE HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH IT.
JOINING US NOW, NATIONAL
SPOKESPERSON FOR RACIAL
EQUALITY.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU BOTH ON.
ALL RIGHT, YOU CAN TAKE IT AWAY.
THESE GUYS ARE BIG GUYS.
THEY’RE INCREDIBLY TALENTED ON
THE COURT.
BUT, BOY, THEY CAN DISH IT OUT
TO TRUMP, USE THE F BOMB, CALL
HIM ALL SORTS OF NAMES, SAY HE
DOESN’T CARE ABOUT PEOPLE, ALL
THIS STUFF, BUT WHEN I CALL THEM
OUT FOR THEIR INSIPID
COMMENTARY, THEY IMMEDIATELY
THROW DOWN THE RACE CARD.
>> THIS IS THE NEW NORM FOR THE
LEFT.
WHEN WHITE CONSERVATIVES CALL
THE BLACK LIBERALS CLUELESS,
THEY’RE CALLED A RACIST.
THAT’S WHAT THESE PEOPLE DO.
THEY’RE BULLIES.
THEY DON’T WANT TO TALK ABOUT
TOPICS.
AND THE PROBABLY WE’RE HAVING
NOW IS WE’RE HAVING TOO MANY,
QUOTE, LEADERS GOING FROM POOR
TO WEALTHY AND SKIPPING THROUGH
MIDDLE CLASS.
MIDDLE CLASS IS WHERE YOU FIND
EMPATHY, SERVICE, AND
UNDERSTANDING AND RELATIONSHIP.
AND WE’RE MISSING THAT.
WE’VE GOT ELITIST THAT THINK
THEY KNOW EVERYTHING, AND THEY
DON’T.
THESE ARE ATHLETES,
ENTERTAINERS, AND NOTHING MORE.
>> THIS WAS LEBRON JAMES.
IT WAS EPIC 2016 CHAMPIONSHIP
PARADE.
CLEVELAND FINALLY WINS THE
CHAMPIONSHIP.
IT WAS A BIG DEAL.
HE WAS HAVING FUN.
THERE WAS A LOT OF FAMILIES
THERE.
LET’S WATCH.
>> I BELIEVE I’M GOING TO WAKE
UP AND IT’S GOING TO BE LIKE
GAME FOUR ALL OVER AGAIN [BLEEP]
[BLEEP].
AND LEBRON JAMES MAKES SIX
STRAIGHT APPEARANCES.
YOU HAD TO BE ALL ANCHORING AT
THE INTERIOR AND YOU LOOKED AT
ME LIKE, MAN, [BLEEP].
I LOVE ALL OF Y’ALL [BLEEP] AND
GET READY FOR NEXT YEAR.
>> HE WAS HAVING FUN.
>> ADDICTED TO THE F BOMB, HUH
>>
>>IT WAS A COUPLE OF F BOMBS.
HE WAS HAVING FUN, BUT COME ON,
HE’S LIKE A CLOWN.
HE’S DONE A LOT OF GOOD STUFF,
LIKE A LOT OF GOOD CHARITY WORK.
BUT IF YOU’RE GOING TO TALK LIKE
THAT AND YOU’RE GOING TO ACT
LIKE THAT AND YOU TALK LIKE THAT
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, I TELL YOU
SOMETHING, IF YOU’RE A WHITE NBA
PLAYER AND YOU SAID THAT STUFF
ABOUT OBAMA, YOU WOULD NEVER
PLAY AGAIN.
>> I THINK HE CALLED THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES A
BUM AND USED THE F BOMB IN
DESCRIBING HIM IN THAT ESPN
PODCAST AS WELL.
>> KEVIN DURANT SAID THE
COMMENT, "SHUT UP AND DRIBBLE,"
IS RACIST TODAY.
>> HE’S RUNNING AWAY FROM YOU.
FOR A GUY THAT’S WINNING NBA
CHAMPIONSHIPS AND HAD THAT KIND
OF STATURE, IT’S A LITTLE WEAK.
>> THIS IS MY POINT.
IF YOU WANT TO BE A POLITICAL
PUNDIT, YOU’RE COMING ON MY
COURT.
LET’S DO IT.
LET’S HAVE A REAL CONVERSATION
ABOUT BLACK UNEMPLOYMENT.
LET’S TALK ABOUT VIOLENCE IN THE
INNER CITY.
LET’S TALK ABOUT ALL THE ISSUES
LIKE SCHOOL CHOICE.
LET’S DO IT.
DON’T THINK YOU’RE NOT GOING TO
GET CRITICIZED IF ALL YOU DO IS
A DRIVE-BY HIT ON TRUMP AND SAY
HE’S NO LEADER.
>> CALL HIM A BUM.
>> IF YOU’RE GOING TO DO IT,
THEN DO IT.
LET’S HAVE A REAL CONVERSATION.
>> AND THAT’S THE THING.
THEY’RE NOT GOING TO HAVE A REAL
CONVERSATION BECAUSE IT TAKES
THINKING AND REALLY TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT ANSWERS.
FOR INSTANCE, I MIGHT NOT AGREE
WITH EVERYTHING WITH CHARLES
BARKLEY, I’M NOT SURE.
I HAVE A LOT OF RESPECT ABOUT
THAT GUY.
HE’S SHOWN ME HE CARES MORE
ABOUT HIS RACE AND BEING
POPULAR.
THESE OTHER GUYS HAVE TO DEAL
WITH THE REAL WORLD.
I CAME OUT OF THE NBA AFTER TEN
YEARS A FLAMING LIBERAL.
THE ANECDOTE TO THAT WAS TAKE MY
COCKY LIBERAL ATTITUDE, AND
FAILING.
IN THE MEANWHILE, WE NEED TO
FIND THREE ENTERPRISES.
LET’S MAKE OUR HEROES
ENTREPRENEURS, NOT THESE